okay so after leaving you guys on the
cliffiest of cliffhangers left you guys
hanging like sylvester stallone
uh i figured i would go ahead and wrap
up this story
yes now technically this is the
aftermath of the invincible war which i
feel like i should change the title of
the last video that we did because
technically it was called invincible
war but this really just kind of gives
us a few little tidbits and then like a
massive fight right so kind of wrapping
up from some of the stuff that we saw
right the whole conflict with
invincibles kind of rampaging across the
world and stuff like that there's a few
things that go on for example if you
guys remember
russ livingston the astronaut that came
back from mars with the little aliens
attached to him he's still there
right and he was still living in that
apartment the whole place was trashed
and a couple of firemen come in to sort
of clean the place out and of course
they get ensnared and they help them
find a new place against their will but
they do it anyway
immortal who was basically killed of
course is brought back as you would
expect with with the immortal himself
mark is offered a position to kind of
lead the the guardians of the globe mark
turns it down
he's like he's injured my mind's not in
it i have no desire to be a part of any
of that or any of that kind of stuff and
so mark ends up going out to basically
deal with cleanup duty right to help
remove
a lot of the rubble and to help people
out stuff like that here's kind of an
interesting thing right i don't know how
many of you guys know this
um but one of the things that happens
when they have like major incidents like
this right huge buildings collapse
things like that you can't just
go in with like an auger right or like a
backhoe and just start digging up rubble
because it could very well be that a
five foot long two by four
is the only thing keeping all that stuff
intact and if you pull that out it'll
all just come crashing down
and any survivors that might be there
are killed right so you have to be super
careful in terms of how you do it that's
why the process takes so long so you
wouldn't normally see a person doing
what mark's doing here which is
basically just grabbing giant chunks of
debris and just throwing them out of the
way
you wouldn't really see that process but
in the midst of mark doing all this
cleanup there's a couple things to know
one there's an exceedingly high level of
guilt here and a lot of this stems from
the fact that he let angstrom levy lift
and angstrom levy living is what led to
all this in the first place when
angstrom levy just basically went around
all those different realities grabbed
all those versions of invincible brought
them here
and then had them all basically go on a
campaign to conquer the world and to
smear the the name of mark in the hopes
that that of course ancient would help
them
conquer their own dimensions right or
find new dimensions to conquer rather uh
and so mark's feeling
a lot of regret here and where you would
expect this to be a time when he could
deal with all this regret and all this
for all this remorse
suddenly he's met by the arrival of a
viltromite who shows up here and says i
am your replacement
if you guys recall that discussion that
he had with anissa she said like there's
gonna be a vulture might who will come
here it could be six months it could be
six years who knows but they will come
here and they will be appointed to
replace you to basically assess
everything you've done and if you have
not conquered this world in the name of
the vulture by empire or you're not on
your way to doing so
they'll kill you and they'll take your
place and that's basically what this guy
is right he's like i'm here to take this
place over by the by the empire
at this point mark's not having it man
mark's like no look i am in no position
to listen to this man like i am this is
not a good time for you to come here
with your little preaches
about how you're you're here to to fix
my mistakes and refusing to conquer this
world and like this guy's like it
doesn't really matter right like my
name's conquest i have
never failed to assimilate a chosen
planet no matter how strong it is
you can oppose me if you want to but
just know that if you do you're gonna
die
right and mark mark comes back with this
amazing line right he's just like ever
since all this popped off
right like this world that i care about
all the people on it like they've
they've been ripped to pieces multiple
times right first it was my dad and it
was various villains and then it's then
like it's this
all these marks from alternate realities
that came here and all that kind of
stuff what i feel right now
is anger right i feel guilt and i feel
shame and the only thing that i've
thought about
since all this has popped off the only
thing that i've wanted to do
was hit something as hard as i can thank
you for coming here conquest
you now have a purpose and like a fight
breaks out between these guys now let me
tell you something man this fight is
brutal i mean it is it is intense and if
i'm being honest with you guys i think
it's more intense than the fight between
mark and his dad
right like it's it was nuts right this
this fight was amazing
now as soon as this breaks out right
cecil's like are you serious man like of
all the times this could have happened
it's gotta happen
now right like in the middle of all of
this it's gotta happen now so here's a
crazy thing his scientific guy right the
guy who was making like the the rihanna
man and all that kind of stuff sinclair
apparently what they've done is they've
taken the bodies of the
invincibles who were killed and they're
reanimating them they're turning them
into soldiers right now it's taking a
long time to do but cecil man this guy's
always up to something man
when we first started a missile i told
you guys cecil man this guy's not to be
trusted right like this guy's got
problems like he's
he's a bad guy right he's got issues now
going back to mark
and conquest that's honestly all you
guys really care about here going back
to marking conquest
this fight is nuts right because mark's
kind of punching him here and there and
kind of getting the upper hand on him a
little bit or seeming to do that and at
the end he's kind of like okay look like
it's one of these things where it's
almost like this guy's kind of goading
him on
as they fight he's like you know that's
a that's a good punch right it's cute
but the important thing here is mark's
like okay like he's doing everything he
can against that guy kind of fighting
but one thing to know
mark's continuing to hold back mark is
still still
operating with this ridiculous
assumption that heroes shouldn't
kill people unless they absolutely have
to right it's the last resort of a
superhero like they're
like there's a time when it's just like
okay look this just needs to happen
right like there's no holding back
there's no you know well you know i
gotta pull my punches i gotta make sure
i do the right thing and take the high
ground because you know that's what
heroes do
and like no no there comes a time when
it's just like you're a bad guy time to
die and like that's it
into the end of the road right done
there's no slippery slope argument here
all you have to do is just create a code
of ethics for yourself which
may include killing people and create
parameters when whereby
it is acceptable to kill people right
just because you're a superhero says you
know what there are people you know i
kill people sometimes doesn't mean you
kill everyone
all the time those are two sickly
different things right and one does not
lead to the other they don't have to
because you're a sentient functioning
human being so here's a crazy thing
right like
while this whole great big huge fight's
going on between mark and and
conquest his mom of course is watching
the whole thing unfold but so is oliver
and oliver basically bolts off right to
go hang out with mark now the crazy
thing is
despite all this going on mark and
conquest are still too fast for oliver
but he's doing what he can now this is
the biggest
issue that oliver has right mark's
biggest problem is he doesn't kill
anybody even when he needs to and even
when it's the best choice to make
oliver's problem is he's reckless that's
oliver's problem he'll just
jump right into a conflict without
giving it any real thought or any real
measure as to what it is that he should
be doing or if he should even be here
in the first place now mark tries to
stop conquest for a second tries to
reason with him for a second but again
the failing of mark the desire to talk
the desire to reason the desire to use
words and so oliver steps in
and that's kind of the thing right as
soon as oliver jumps in like conquest
like who who the heck are you you know
and he's like well it doesn't matter you
know don't worry about that oliver tells
him his breath smells like feet which is
probably true and so so much like okay
right like mark sends oliver out of
there says you gotta get out of here you
can't stay here and that's when conquest
kind of chimes in and that's the funny
thing about this right that's the
interesting thing about this
if you guys go back and like you watch
the scene on amazon when mark fights his
dad
or you read about it in the comics his
father is teaching him to fight
as a viltromite while they fight right
he's basically giving him lessons he's
teaching him what it means to be
somebody who can basically face
against all comers and that's the whole
that's the whole philosophy that's what
it means to really be a superhero is
sometimes you just gotta kill and that's
the lesson that conquest is teaching
mark now he's not teaching it out of
altruism right he's not here to be a
mentor he's here to kill the guy
right like he's here to kill mark but
it's an inadvertent lesson that's being
taught to him right more tells oliver no
go get out of here the response of
conquest
is you idiot you need all the help that
you can get lesson being taught here you
can't always win on your own and
sometimes you really need to ask for
help in these times when you're facing
such an
insurmountable threat that you just
can't defeat it by yourself right the
other part of this is he asked him like
where's your vulture my heart you know
until i see it beating in my hand
i won't believe that you have it show me
your power show me your rage constantly
pushing mark constantly pushing mark and
that's been kind of the secret behind
mark this entire time
mark holds back because he's trying to
be the good guy he's trying to be the
good thing he has not figured out yet
but there are some points you just you
just gotta do the guy in and fighting
back against conquest as best he can
when he goes in for a punch conquest
catches his fist and says if this is all
the strength that you possess
this is not gonna end well for you so if
you're serious about this fight then
fight like you're serious
but if you're not serious about this
fight let me know now put your guard
down and i'll just i'll take you out
right i'll kill you right here and now
and then as soon as i'm done i'll kill
everybody else right like my goal here
is to prep this world for the arrival of
the viltrumide empire and i will achieve
my goal whether you're alive or not and
so you switch over to e for a second
right now i told you guys
i told you guys in the early days we
were doing the invincible run eve would
become incredibly important
and she would become astronomically
powerful right she would become
hugely powerful so much so she would be
the most powerful person throughout the
entire roster of the invincible comics
this comes when eve
wakes up right doesn't come in this
exact moment but it starts when eve
wakes up now she ends up seeing the tv
mark's basically facing off against some
crazy guy out there her mom makes a
statement while mark is fighting against
his father
you know and she's like okay he's like
okay he's fighting against somebody out
there maybe it's not his dad i have no
idea maybe it is who knows but you kind
of get this little bit of a back and
forth right where he's like okay
she basically ends up you know having
the doctor get a hold of see so so cecil
can teleport her directly to where mark
is fighting because obviously she won't
be able to get there fast enough or
can't get there as fast as she would
like to be her bones are broken right i
mean like her leg
legs broken you know she's got all kinds
of injuries she doesn't care right so
from there you switch back over to mark
right and again conquest
is just kind of tearing into him and
just kind of like like really just
goading him along the way like this this
doesn't really i mean as much as
as much as it seems to be an even fight
and in some way it is it's also
completely
uneven right i mean one like conquest
looks older than nolan which means he
seems to have lived a lot longer than
nolan has nola's been around for a few
thousand years so conquest seems to have
been around longer than that but he even
goes as far as to say like i've met your
father right like i never spent a whole
lot of time with him but like i met him
right he showed so much promise and now
he's dead right i heard his execution
finally went off without a hitch you
know and this that's really sad because
i would love to have seen the look on
your father's face when i told him i
came to the world that used to be his
and i killed his son right inner oliver
oliver comes flying in just just come
swoop it in right says this guy flying
and then he's then like the guy's right
back on his feet again right and the
whole time mark mark being an idiot is
like no oliver you can't be here all
over you gotta go you can't stay oliver
you know you gotta you gotta go you
gotta go be safe and ultimately like
oliver gets picked up by by conquest he
starts to rip him in half
mark responds and starts pummeling this
guy the damn breaks
mark's had enough right like marcus mark
is sick and tired of all this guy's
nonsense but even then
like even him fighting he's still not
able to really put the put the marks
into this guy
to really pummel and beat this guy down
the way that he needs to
enter adam eve now when adam eve shows
up here man it is
man it's a sight to behold right it's
one of the craziest things so adam eve
shows up here she's like you're not omni
man and he's like yeah bad news for you
mark steps in and tells out of me you
got to get out of here right like
conquest
breaks mark's leg goes after adam eve
like she creates a force field around
him he shatters the force field he's
like girl your problems are just
beginning right punches this girl in the
face
boom impales her through the stomach
that's the end of adam even this is like
wow like he just killed adam eve holy
cow right like he just killed this girl
mark's just like what you know and
that's that's this is it right this is
this is this is the snap
this is it right here right this is the
snap this is the crazy thing about this
right here's a crazy thing about this so
mark goes to comforter
the damn breaks right mark's just like
nope done like like we're not we're not
playing we're not playing this game
because he starts to basically
like like make fun of it he's like so
she's finally dead damn it took her long
enough she must have been a really great
girl if she came he came all the way
here
just to die in front of you right you
know that's crazy he's like god you know
her blood does taste delicious you know
like
like literally just goating this guy
taunting him right and mark's like
that's it i'm done like i don't care how
strong you are i don't care how fast you
are
i've been to the future and you don't
live to see tomorrow like you do not
live to see the future
mark completely snaps right like any any
chance
this guy had against mark is gone these
guys go flying towards each other mark
shatters his robotic hand so this guy is
down one hand
and mark just starts pulling this guy
and he's literally doing everything he
can right he bites this guy when i say
bite i mean he takes a chunk out of it
right like takes a huge chunk out of him
now while all that's going on eve starts
powering up right just all this light
energy just starts powering up out of
nowhere and then literally it's just
this huge explosion of like a force of
energy while mark's just beating the
crap
out of conquest and then in this moment
when eve kind of flashes out that she
gets mark's attention for a split second
and then you have conquest who gets the
upper hand on mark and then eve
completely reforms her body blasts up
last conquest with all this energy
incinerates his skin on his body eve
passes out
mark takes the opportunity and just
starts just starts smashing this guy
right like just headbutting him into
oblivion to the point that this guy's
face is just
absolutely mush right just just crushing
this guy and he's like
done right like that's it like like i'm
done you know like mark just
snaps you know at that point he gets
over to where he's at and
he was like am i naked and he's like
yeah you're kind of a little bit naked
and then mark passes out and eve kind of
passes out but unless of course
mark wakes up later in the hospital
eve's at his side and she's kind of like
oh man you were so brave you know like
you fought that guy now of course there
is the funeral for rex splode and this
is kind of interesting right after
mark's recovering and kind of getting
back one of the things that does happen
is he does meet with cecil and he's like
show me the body of this guy right like
cecil shows him the body and he's like
okay
i just needed to know he was dead right
after everything that happened with
angstrom levy he needed to know this guy
was actually dead right because he left
angstrom levee for dead only for ancient
levy to actually be alive and start
unleashing holy hell with all these
marks and everything and so when you get
to this kind of funeral between or
really with with rex splode there's a
lot that kind of goes on there
right like you've got this whole thing
with eve where she's having a very
difficult time with it
not necessarily because of the fact that
she's deeply in love with rex
a lot of this is because of the fact
that he was her first right i mean
that's the thing there's a
kind of emotional bond that forms with
someone when they're your first
she never got to say goodbye and see and
and knowing that he died because he
sacrificed his life
to save others around him was something
that she never thought that he would
ever do right she always thought that he
would always be a jerk and so there's a
little bit of of remorse and regret here
you know
because she she asked mark she's like
you know can i say that i loved him you
know is it is it weird if i say that and
mark
mark being a man of confidence is like
no i mean i wouldn't be mad about that
right you know if you're like an
insecure guy you're like no i don't want
to hear you say that because i'm afraid
that you might you know reanimate his
corpse and date him
you know but but he's like yeah i mean
it makes perfect sense like i was your
first
you guys spent a lot of time together i
mean there was a bond there that you and
he had that you and i just won't have
right because of the the the things that
the parts of yourselves that you shared
in a way that you'd never done it before
and so he's kind of like you know it's
totally understandable that you feel the
way that you feel it's totally
understandable
that you're crushed like that and so
what you end up doing is you end up
jumping
to the the block which as you guys know
is largely the prison that's kind of ran
by cecil
and of course this is out in some
defense outposts you know out in the
mojave desert and you've got cecil there
and what you have there
is the head of conquest and his infinite
wisdom
what cecil has done here is he showed
mark
a fake body that was not actually
conquest the body the cecil showed mark
that was not actually him
and instead what's happened is he's put
conquest in a 400 ton
block of solid tempered steel and that
conquest
is not actually dead like most vulture
bites he's wildly durable and
of course his healing factor is kicking
in and his body is basically healing the
intention of cecil
is that when he snaps back right when he
comes back that cecil is going to
basically interrogate conquest so
conquest will tell him
everything he wants to know about the
viltrumite empire of course
we will come back to that later on down
the line but this kind of ends when you
have mark having a conversation with
oliver
and this is cool because as the two of
them are talking that oliver's kind of
asking about how eve's doing and so on
and how mom's doing and and basically
mark's kind of giving you know feeling a
man you know all that kind of stuff and
then mark expresses this deep
frustration of the fact that he thought
all this was over
right he thought that like this was all
said and done that he could finally have
some measure of peace in his life
and of course the vulture might just
keep on coming and so when oliver
apologizes and he says look i'm sorry
about everything that's happened the
response of mark is no i'm the one who
should be apologizing to you right the
past few weeks
i've been training you i think i've
learned more than you have
right i've scolded you i've yelled at
you thought i knew better
i thought you were misguided and naive
but i was wrong
you were right the whole time but i
never learned my lesson he says someone
tries to hurt my family
someone i love if there's another
villain out there putting lives in
danger who's just gonna keep coming at
me until they finally succeed
i won't hesitate to kill them mark has
finally grown up
mark has left this kind of wide-eyed
childhood naivety behind and he's
accepted the world
as it exists and has accepted the fact
that you can't always win
with rainbows and hearts and and love
and shiny pretty things and a desire to
understand other people's feelings
the world doesn't work that way that the
world can be harsh
and the world can be brutal and it can
be cruel it's not always like that but
there are times when it is and people
who follow this philosophy that like
kindness and happiness and understanding
feelings is the way to make it in the
world they don't last
right they they just they cannot make it
in those hard times and so mark
understanding that philosophy and mark
understanding there are times when i'm
going to have to go to the limit and
there are times when i'm going to have
to kill people
that's him growing up and accepting the
way the world
is it's one of the coolest revelations
of the entirety of the story so with
that being said guys
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace